.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Sie sind gerade rausgekommen.
Was überlegst du?
Ich beobachte.
Sie sind sehr, sehr unruhig.
Sie sammeln sich sofort
bei jedem Geräusch.
Ich möchte wissen,
in welche Richtung sie ziehen.
Und das ist
ein abgeerntetes Getreidefeld.
Das ist sehr laut,
um mich anzuschleichen.
Spürst du das Adrenalin
in diesen Situationen
oder ist das schon lange vorbei?
Es ist nicht ... Warte kurz!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 ...
... 7, 8, 9, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18 -
19 Stück.
Wir versuchen mal, uns anzupirschen.
Ein halbes Jahr
begleite ich Fabian Kern.
Er ist Wildhüter der Stadt Zürich.
Ich selber
bin in der Ausbildung zum Jäger
und möchte wissen:
Was genau macht ein Wildhüter?
Die Schlange im Keller,
der Dachs im Vorgarten
und Vögel auf der Baustelle -
das alles werde ich
mit Wildhüter Kern erleben.
Aber: der Reihe nach.
Rund ein Viertel der Stadt Zürich
ist Wald.
Diese Waldfläche
gilt als Wildschongebiet für Rehe,
Hirsche und sogar Gämsen.
Das Jagen
ist hier Aufgabe der Wildhüter.
Privates Jagen ist nicht erlaubt.
Wildhüter überprüfen die Population
und greifen - wenn nötig - ein.
Ich treffe Fabian Kern
frühmorgens im Stadtwald.
Wir sind auf der Rehjagd.
Wir nehmen jedes Jahr eine bestimmte
Anzahl Rehe aus dem Bestand.
Im Moment sind Schmalrehe,
weibliche Tiere
aus dem letzten Jahr,
die keine Jungen haben,
und Böcke offen zur Jagd.
Hier im Wald
jagen wir v.a. die Rehböcke.
Und in diesem Gebiet
hatte letztes Jahr eine Rehgeiss
zwei männliche Kitze.
Ich möchte gerne
einen der zwei erlegen.
Wie viele müsst ihr erlegen?
Wir kriegen Vorgaben
von der kantonalen Fischerei-
und Jagdverwaltung.
Das bewegt sich immer so
zwischen 120 und 160 oder 180 Rehen
im ganzen Stadtgebiet.
Im Dickicht erspäht Wildhüter Kern
mit dem Nachtsichtgerät zwei Rehe.
Doch wir waren wohl zu laut:
Das Reh schreckt,
wie es in der Fachsprache heisst.
* Bellartige Geräusche *
Das ist die Rehgeiss.
Mit diesem Bellen, dem Schrecken,
warnt sie die anderen Rehe vor uns.
Dann zeigt sich ein Rehbock.
Der könnte passen.
Das ist ein Rehbock
vom letzten Jahr.
Das wäre eigentlich
ein guter Abgang.
Aber er steht auf einem Privatareal.
Da dürfen wir nicht jagen.
Auf Privatgrundstücken
darfst du also nicht jagen?
In Notfällen dürfen wir
auch auf Privatgrundstücke,
um kranke oder verletzte Tiere
zu erlösen.
Aber ich habe schon mit
dem Liegenschaftsbesitzer gesprochen
und er möchte das nicht.
- Okay.
Das muss man respektieren.
Zudem
ist es ein wunderschöner Fleck.
Das ist ein Austritt,
wo die Rehe rauskönnen.
So stehen sie nicht nur im Wald.
Das sei ihnen gegönnt.
Gefällt dir dein Job?
Was soll ich sagen? Ich kann mir
nichts Besseres vorstellen.
Welcher Teil des Jobs
gefällt dir am wenigsten?
So komisch es klingt:
manchmal das Jagen selber.
Mhm.
Da hat sich viel verändert,
seit ich das beruflich mache.
Es fällt mir nicht immer gleich
leicht, auf die Jagd zu gehen.
Fabian Kern gibt mir ein Zeichen,
stehen zu bleiben.
Bei einem Schuss
will er nicht gefilmt werden.
Das sei
aus Respekt dem Tier gegenüber.
* Schuss *
Wir warten jetzt einen Moment
und gehen dann zusammen nach vorne.
Aber es müsste alles gut sein.
Hat man da ein bisschen
ein schlechtes Gewissen?
Nein, das nicht.
Aber man ist Herr
über Leben und Tod.
Wenn einen das emotional
gar nicht berühren würde,
wäre man am falschen Ort.
Dann ist man auch als Jäger
am falschen Ort.
Es muss schon
eine Sinnhaftigkeit haben.
Die man sich
auch nicht nur einredet.
Also, dass man wirklich weiss, dass
das verhaltensbiologisch Sinn macht.
Ich ersetze ein Grossraubtier, das
es im Zürcher Stadtwald nicht gibt.
Ein Reh hat einen Bewegungsradius
von 300-400 m.
Man merkt einfach sofort,
wenn die Dichte zu hoch wird:
Es gibt kranke Tiere und Tiere,
die auf die Strasse rauskommen.
Fabian, man könnte sagen,
dass das perfekt ist.
Es lief so, wie es sollte, oder?
- Ja.
Aufgrund dessen,
was sich da zeigt ...
Das Reh
ist einfach zusammengebrochen.
Es hörte nicht mal den Schuss.
Eigentlich so,
wie ich mir das wünsche,
auch für das Tier.
Dass meine Arbeit
genau diese Perfektion zeigt,
sobald es um Leben und Tod geht.
Das muss man anstreben.
Wenn es einem gelingt,
das so umzusetzen,
ist das erreicht,
was es auch ausmacht.
Ich werde das Tier jetzt deponieren.
Damit
es nicht so an der Strasse liegt.
Und dann hole ich das Auto
und wir laden es auf
und verarbeiten es weiter.
Macht man das,
damit man kein totes Reh sieht,
wenn man vorbeiläuft?- Genau.
Diese Massnahme ist nötig,
weil im Stadtwald
viele Menschen unterwegs sind.
Fabian Kern erzählt mir,
dass er immer wieder
beschimpft und bedroht wird.
Dieser Passant hier ist dem Wildhüter
allerdings wohlgesonnen.
Wenigstens wissen Sie von jemanden,
dass das geschätzt wird.
Sehr schön. Danke vielmals.
Schönes Wochenende.
Ist das Alltag oder triffst du auch
Leute, die sich anders verhalten?
Es gibt beides.
Es gibt viele Leute,
die schätzen, dass wir -
also, nicht ich als Wildhüter,
sondern wir als Stadt Zürich -
einen Lebensraum schaffen,
auch für den Menschen.
Es gibt auch andere Leute, die
vielleicht aus Mangel an Verständnis
gewisse Situationen
falsch einschätzen.
Meine Tätigkeit ist exponiert
wegen des Gewehrs.
Das verstehen nicht alle.
Aber mit Aufklärungsarbeit und Ge-
sprächen kann man da viel erreichen.
Dann gibt es Leute, zu denen
wir gar keinen Zugang finden.
Die legen den Fokus
nur auf die Waffe
oder darauf, dass ich Tiere töte.
Aber auch die Leute
muss man mit Respekt behandeln.
Ja.
Gerade weil er so exponiert ist,
hält sich der Wildhüter
und Ex-Polizist zurück,
was sein Privatleben anbelangt.
Laut Lebensmittelgesetz
muss er das Reh
innerhalb von 90 Min. verarbeiten.
Aber es gibt genügend
Zeit für ein wichtiges Ritual.
Warum machst du das?
Die Hunde sind Teil meines Rudels.
Ich bin ihr Chef
und wir machen zusammen Beute.
Das hilft ein bisschen,
die Beziehung zu vertiefen.
Gleichzeitig
sollen sie sich auch daran gewöhnen,
denn ich möchte nicht,
dass sie zu hart aufs Wild gehen.
Das ist schon gut.
Elva, geh rein. Hopp, einsteigen.
So.
Der Rehbock wird auf das Areal
der Grün Stadt Zürich gebracht.
Hier kann der Wildhüter
das Tier verarbeiten und untersuchen.
Isst du selbst auch viel Wildfleisch?
Zu 95 % nur Wild, ja.
Fabian Kern erhält das Wildfleisch
aber nicht umsonst -
das Reh ist Eigentum der Stadt.
Man sieht hier
das Hämatom des Schusses.
Ansonsten
ist das eine einwandfreie Leber.
Die Nieren
schneidet man so längs auf,
um sie zu beurteilen.
Die verschiedenen Farben müssten
so schön abgegrenzt sein, genau.
Das Tier ist bedenkenlos,
um es in den Konsum zu bringen.
Jedes Tier, das
in die Lebensmittelproduktion geht,
erhält eine Wildmarke.
Das garantiert
die Rückverfolgbarkeit.
Man könnte also rausfinden,
dass es von dir erlegt wurde.
Rein theoretisch
muss das möglich sein.
Anschliessend
geht das Tier in den Kühlschrank
und wartet auf einen Abnehmer.
In diesem Fall
wird es an einen Metzger verkauft.
Nebenan befindet sich Kerns Büro.
Alle Angaben über den geschossenen
Rehbock muss er festhalten.
Büroarbeit und Sitzungen - auch das
sind Aufgaben eines Stadtwildhüters.
Ho-hopp.
Immer mit dabei:
die Hunde Dixie und Elva.
Da Wildhüter immer wieder
verletze Tiere aufsuchen müssen,
ist der Besitz eines ausgebildeten
Jagdhundes eine Voraussetzung.
Dixie.
Brauchst du auch deinen Auslauf?
Ich würde lügen, wenn ich sage,
es sei nicht schön,
zwischen zwei Sitzungen
kurz rauszugehen.
Elva hat das Hasengehege entdeckt.
Elva, komm. So ist fein.
Ja, so ist fein.
Komm. Lass sie. Nein.
Nein.
* Lockere Musik *
Fertig.
Hey.
Komm jetzt.
Hey! Elva, fertig.
(Lachend) Fertig.
So, finito jetzt. Dix!
Elva macht Sitz. Sitz!
Dixie, komm. Es ist gut.
Ohne Leine.
Elva, komm jetzt.
So, jetzt: Hund abtragen.
So.
Ein Bauer meldet mögliche Wild-
schweinschäden in seinem Haferfeld.
Fabian muss ausrücken.
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Aufgrund des Schadenbildes
ist das gut möglich, ja.
Es macht
keinen ganz frischen Eindruck.
Man riecht auch nichts.
Es riecht nicht nach Wildschwein.
Wie riechen Wildschweine?
Wildschweine ...
Das ist so ... Äh ...
Es gibt diesen Vergleich,
es rieche wie Maggi-Würze.
Wildschweine vermehren sich
rasanter als z.B. Rehe
und können erhebliche Schäden
in der Landwirtschaft verursachen.
Zur Aufgabe der Wildhüter gehört es,
die Population zu kontrollieren.
Vielleicht sehen wir,
wo sie reingehen.
Je nachdem schauen wir heute Abend,
ob wir eines der Jungen
schiessen können.
Das ist so ein Vergrämungsabschuss.
Dann merken die Bachen,
dass es hier gefährlich ist.
Dann führt sie ihre Jungen
nicht mehr hierher.
Das Jagen ist nur ein Teil
seiner Aufgabe als Wildhüter.
Meist vermittelt er
zwischen Wildtieren und Menschen.
Ich habe einen Anruf von einem
Bürger in Zürich Witikon erhalten.
Er hat mir gesagt,
er habe eine Schlange im Schacht.
Das ist keine alltägliche Arbeit
und gehört eigentlich auch nicht
zu den Kernkompetenzen
von uns Wildhütern.
Aber es ist ein wildes Tier.
Ich weiss, dass es in Witikon
immer mal wieder Ringelnattern hat.
Darum versuchen wir
einerseits der Schlange
wie auch dem Hausbewohner zu helfen.
Nimmst du eine Spezialausrüstung mit?
- Sicher mal Handschuhe.
Und eine Taschenlampe.
Dann schaue ich mir das an.
Ob ich sie überhaupt sehe.
Dann schauen wir,
was ich sonst noch brauche.
Am Samstag
lief ich hier barfuss rum.
Mein Nachbar mähte den Rasen.
Mhm.
Ich war barfuss und trat fast ...
Er war richtig erschrocken
und meinte, sie würde mich beissen.
Wie lange ist sie ungefähr?
Ich würde sagen,
zwischen 50 und 70 cm.
50 cm sicher. Aber 70 cm ...
- Okay.
Gibt es giftige Schlangen bei uns?
Nein ... Also, doch ...
Nein, gibt es nicht.
Also keine, die gefährlich werden.
- Eben.
Ist das da unten die Waschküche?
- Hm?
Ist das die Waschküche?
Das Büro
meiner verstorbenen Geliebten.- Oh.
Kann man dort rein
und durchs Fenster rausschauen?
Das können Sie.
Ja ... Nein, der hält nicht.
Das ist ...- ... heikel?
Ja.
Haben Sie einen Tritthocker oder so?
Ich schaue mal.
Lassen Sie das Fenster mal noch zu,
ich schaue erst von hier.
Soll ich das zulassen?
- Ja.
Dann gehe ich ...
- Siehst du was?
Bis jetzt nichts.
Aber sie kann gut unter diesen
grossen Steinen verkrochen sein.
Ich denke, ich muss die Steine
mal vorsichtig wegräumen.
Wenn es eine Ringelnatter ist -
was ich vermute ...
Die haben die Eigenschaft ...
Das sind ja Amphibienfresser.
Sie fressen v.a. Molche,
Frösche und Kröten.
Die haben sehr scharfe Zähne.
Es ist nicht auszuschliessen,
dass sie beissen wird.
Sie hat keine Giftzähne, aber ...
Ich habe auch Respekt vor der Drüse,
die sie haben.
Damit können sie ein
übel stinkendes Sekret ausscheiden.
Das möchte ich eigentlich
nicht unbedingt
auf meinen Kleidern und meiner Haut.
Das habe ich mal
mit einem Iltis erlebt.
Das kriegt man fast nicht mehr raus.
Ich mache kurz einen Anruf.
Einen Anruf?
- Ich rufe jemanden an.
Soll ich das Telefon bringen?
- Er ruft mit dem Handy an.
Das geht hier unten nicht.
Und mit den Handschuhen
erst recht nicht.
Haben Sie Angst vor Schlangen?
- Nein.
Nein ... Ja ...
Wenn eine 7 m lange Schlange kommt,
würde ich ...
* Nervöses Lachen *
Er hatte Angst.
Er war ganz aufgeregt.
Er meinte, wenn sie eckig sind ...
Also, eckig ...
Wenn der Kopf markant ist,
seien sie giftig oder nicht giftig.
Aber ich hatte keine Zeit,
um darauf zu achten
oder noch
mit dem Massstab zu messen.
* Lachen *
Ich komme rauf,
ich habe keinen Empfang.
Fabian, Wildhüter Stadt Zürich,
grüezi.
Ich habe
wieder mal ein Schlangenthema.
Ein Lichtschacht, rund 1,5 m tief,
mit grossen Bollensteinen.
Seit Samstag ist dort vermutlich
eine Ringelnatter versteckt.
Die verkriecht sich in den Steinen,
oder?
Ist es eine Ringelnatter?
- Das vermutet er.
Die hat ganz viele Bögen gemacht,
ganz viele.
Ich glaube,
die haben einen geringelten Hals.
Nein.
Also ...
Kann ich die Steine umschichten,
um sie zu suchen?
Ja. Nein, das ist gut.
Ich werde das ausrichten.
Prima. Danke vielmals.
Danke. Tschüss. Tschau.
Das war der Reptilienspezialist
der Kantonspolizei.- Ja.
Er meinte,
wir würden die nicht erwischen.
Wenn wir die Steine bewegen,
verkriecht sie sich immer mehr.
Dann verschwindet sie immer mehr.
- Genau.
Wir sollen als Ausstieg
ein Holzbrett schräg reinstellen.
Das habe ich mir auch gedacht.
So.
Sind die schützenswert?
- Ja, die sind schon schützenswert.
Und man will ja nicht, dass ein Tier
an so einem Ort stirbt.
Der Wildhüter -
so habe ich den Eindruck -
hilft den Menschen
nicht nur bei ungebetenen Tieren,
sondern er ist auch eine willkommene
Abwechslung in ihrem Alltag.
Eine Baustelle in Zürich Nord.
Die Bauleitung hat
bei der Sanierung eines Dachstockes
Vogelgezwitscher vernommen.
Die Vögel beim Brüten zu stören
ist gemäss Jagdgesetz verboten.
Es drohen Bussen bis zu 10'000 Fr.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ja, krass.
- Siehst du was?
Ja, es hat unzählige Wespennester.
Das sind wirklich unzählige.
Du magst Wespen auch nicht so,
oder?
Nein. Ich bin sogar allergisch.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Jetzt hat man sie gehört.
Eigentlich reicht es,
die Vögel so zu hören.
Den Teil der Baustelle kann ich noch
nicht mit gutem Gewissen freigeben.
Offenbar
geht es hier um einen Hausrotschwanz.
Die Sanierung muss verschoben werden,
bis die Vögel ausgeflogen sind.
Sie müssen zwei Wochen
Baustopp machen wegen des Vogels.
Wie ist das für Sie als Baufirma?
Das sind halt Sachen ...
Normalerweise kommt ein Baupolizist,
eher wegen der Mitarbeitersicherheit
und der Umgebung.
Das ist das erste Mal,
dass mir ein Wildhüter
einen Baustopp auferlegt.
Das wollen wir auch berücksichtigen.
Dafür gibt es auch Gesetze.
Ich melde mich. Danke dir.
- Alles klar. Schönen Tag.
In den letzten Jahren
hat sich v.a. eine Tierart
immer mehr Zugang
in die Stadtgärten verschafft.
Ein Tier,
das Wildhüter Kern gerne mag.
Im Winter kriegte ich die Meldung
von einer Liegenschaftenverwaltung,
die ein grosses Loch im Garten
entdeckt hatte.
Sie wollten wissen, was es ist.
Ich stellte dann
eine Wildtierkamera auf.
Da hatte ich mehrmals einen Dachs
und sehr viele Katzen drauf.
Wir überwachen den Bau noch,
bis wir sicher sind,
dass keine Tiere drin sind.
Dann kann
die Liegenschaftenverwaltung
ein Gartenbauunternehmen
beauftragen,
um ihn zu verschliessen.
Aber der Winter
ist eine schlechte Zeit,
um nachzuweisen,
dass der Bau leer ist.
Der Dachs macht eine Winterruhe.
D.h., es kann sein,
dass er mal ein paar Tage drin ist
und nicht rauskommt.
Um sicher zu sein, legen wir noch
mal neue Batterien in die Kamera
und überwachen den Bau
noch ein paar Tage.
Was haben wir denn da im Garten?
- Einen Dachs.
Wir schauen jetzt.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass es Jungtiere hat.
Wir wollen sicher sein, dass er leer
ist, bevor er verschlossen wird.
Würde es Sie stören, wenn hier
ein Dachs leben würde?- Nein.
Hier stört der Dachs mehr:
im Irchelpark.
Ein Naherholungsgebiet und
ein Standort der Universität Zürich.
Mensch und Tier
kommen sich hier in die Quere.
Das Natur- und Heimatschutzgesetz
verbietet grundsätzlich
die Zerstörung eines Dachsbaus.
Letzte Woche merkten wir,
dass man bei der Grossbaustelle
einen Anschluss an die Kanalisation
quer über den Hang da
vorne ziehen wollte.
Da ist ein riesiger
Dachs-/Fuchsbau drin.
Es wäre durchaus möglich, dass
der Bau schon 30-40 Jahre besteht.
Hier sehen wir
einen der Haupteingänge
dieses grossen Dachsbaus.
Da unten ist die riesige Menge Erde,
die ausgegraben wurde.
Hier hat es
deutliche Hinweise darauf,
dass er im Moment auch bewohnt ist
bzw. befahren, wie wir sagen.
Man sieht hier die Krallen
des Dachses beim Ausstieg,
und dass die Höhle
relativ sauber ist.
Der ist voll in Gebrauch
und bewohnt.
Die Wildkamera
bestätigt Fabian Kerns Annahme:
Hier wohnt eine ganze Dachsfamilie.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich finde den Dachs
so eine spezielle Tierart.
Er lebt hier in der Stadt Zürich
wirklich mitten unter den Leuten.
Die Leute kriegen das aber z.T.
jahrelang nicht mit.
Von seinem Lebensstil
und seinem Willen her
ist er so speziell,
dass es für mich ...
Es muss
einen richtig guten Grund geben,
damit ich einen Dachs
jagdlich erlege.
Der Wildhüter handelt hier
im Interesse des Dachses.
Der Bau bleibt.
Eine Kanalisation wird umgeleitet.
Bei den Wildschweinen
sieht die Situation ganz anders aus.
Hier muss er eingreifen.
Wir treffen uns
wieder am Hönggerberg.
Fabian hat mich im Voraus gewarnt,
dass es
eine lange Nacht werden würde.
Die Wildschweinjagd
findet zu 90 % in der Nacht statt.
Im Schutz der Dunkelheit,
wenn die Tiere auch rauskommen.
Dann können wir sie auch mit
technischen Hilfsmitteln überlisten.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass du
viel Wert auf Jagdethik legst.
Findest du,
dass Nachtzielgeräte fair sind?
Ja.
So können wir besser treffen
und vorher auch besser sehen,
welches Tier es ist
und wie sie zusammengehören.
Damit wir z.B. kein Muttertier
von den Jungen wegschiessen.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Jetzt kam gerade
eine Meldung einer Wildkamera.
Wir stehen rund 120 m weiter unten.
Da sind Wildschweine auf der Kamera.
Wir platzieren uns jetzt hier,
fahren vielleicht noch anders hin.
Die Zeit haben wir.
Jetzt kommen laufend Bilder.
Sie sind gerade rausgekommen.
Was überlegst du?
Ich beobachte.
Sie sind sehr, sehr unruhig.
Sie sammeln sich sofort
bei jedem Geräusch.
Ich möchte wissen,
in welche Richtung sie ziehen.
Und das ist
ein abgeerntetes Getreidefeld.
Das ist sehr laut,
um mich anzuschleichen.
Spürst du das Adrenalin
in diesen Situationen
oder ist das schon lange vorbei?
Es ist nicht ... Warte kurz!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 ...
... 7, 8, 9, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18 -
19 Stück.
Aber auch hier: Wenn es einen
gar nicht mehr berührt,
muss man sich Gedanken machen,
ob man die richtige Arbeit macht.
Wir versuchen mal, uns anzupirschen.
Ich folge Fabian Kerns Anweisungen
und versuche, leise zu sein.
Wildschweine seien sehr aufmerksam
und riechen und hören ausgezeichnet.
Es stehen wieder alle
ganz dicht beieinander
und sind wieder weg von uns.
Wir versuchen es mal da nach oben
und etwas in den Waldrand rein.
Das könnte klappen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Sie stehen jetzt sehr, sehr eng
zusammen und fressen dort etwas.
Es ist unmöglich, eins zu schiessen.
Es ist wirklich nicht möglich.
Bei einem Schuss muss alles stimmen.
U.a. kann Fabian erst dann schiessen,
wenn ein Schwein allein steht.
Etwas scheint die Tiere
aufgeschreckt zu haben.
Jetzt gilt: volle Konzentration
und bewusste Atmung.
Ich erwarte den Schuss
und erschrecke trotzdem.
* Schuss *
Sie liegt da vorne.
(Über Telefon) Kern,
Wildhüter Stadt Zürich, grüezi.
Falls Sie eine Meldung
von der Furttalstrasse erhalten:
Ich habe gerade
ein Wildschwein erlegt.
Danke. Schönen Abend.
Musst du das jedes Mal machen?
Das kommt vielleicht davon,
dass ich früher Polizist war.- Mhm.
Ich musste nachts auch schon wegen
komischer Schüsse im Wald ausrücken.
Einfach, um das zu verhindern.
Wir sind hier halt wirklich
relativ nahe an den Häusern.
Es ist kurz nach Mitternacht, als er
das erlegte Tier zum Auto bringt.
Wie der Rehbock
muss auch das Wildschwein
zeitnah verarbeitet werden.
* Ruhige Musik *
Fertig.
Die Arbeit eines Stadtwildhüters -
so habe ich miterlebt -
ist vielfältig, einsam, nie fertig
und zum grossen Teil unsichtbar.
Doch für das Zusammenleben
von Mensch und Tier in der Stadt
ist er unverzichtbar.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023